okay there is much hubbub being made
over some hacked audio recordings of a
private conversation that Hillary
Clinton had with campaign donors months
ago and i'm going to play the audio for
you a lot of people are emailing me
saying David it's shocking what Hillary
says here she says that she is occupying
both the center left and the center
right this is absolutely insane and when
I heard it when I listen to the audio
that I'll play for you i thought well
yeah we've been saying for years that
Hillary Clinton is one of the more
moderate or center-right Democrats that
are around this is exactly what I would
predict Hillary Clinton says so let's
take a listen to the audio and then
we'll dig into it it is important to
recognize what's going on in this
election everybody who's ever been in
any election that I'm aware of is quite
bewildered because there is a a strain
of the one hand a kind of populist
nationalist xenophobic discriminatory
kind of approach that we hear too much
up from the Republican candidates and on
the other side it there's a just a deep
desire to believe that you know we can
have free college free healthcare that
what we've done hasn't gone far enough
and we just need to you know go as far
as you know Scandinavia whatever that
means and half the people don't know
what it means but it is something that
they deeply feel so as a friend of mine
said the other day I am occupying from
the center left to the center right and
I don't have much company out there
because it is difficult when you're
running to be President and you
understand how hard the job is I don't
want to over promise I don't want to
tell people things that I know we cannot
do I want to level with you
was this some major secret right nobody
would have known that Hillary Clinton is
uh sort of center left center right
without somebody hacking into a phone to
get audio added this is just not
shocking this is what I've been saying
for years about Hillary Clinton and I
don't agree with her that she doesn't
have company occupying the center left
to the center-right the neoconservative
pro-business Republicans that are
they're not in favor of progressive
positions on social issues but they're
sort of indifferent about restricting
people's actions when it comes to social
issues beyond saying some basic things
to raise money from evangelicals but
they they are not that far from Hillary
Clinton here's what center left and
center right or code for in American
politics okay centre-left means I want
to be seen as progressive but I'm
basically a status quo campaign finance
and crony capitalist insider and I want
to keep it that way while appearing
progressive and in order to do that I
will support a somewhat higher minimum
wage I'll talk about equality I'll make
some improvements to social welfare
programs etc that's what centre-left is
code for center-right is code for I'm
not one of these religious nut
Republicans I'm not a social
conservative I don't have these
outrageously black and white views on
the economy or foreign affairs but I'm
basically a standard neoliberal on war
I'm slightly hawkish I'm I'm sort of III
support the military industrial complex
and unformed basically you know liat
neoliberal that's what center left and
center right mean in practice in modern
politics and these are codes Pat that we
now have to understand and interpret and
there's nothing should be of course this
is where Hillary is on the spectrum yeah
this isn't really too surprising I mean
we know that Hillary Clinton's gonna do
whatever is politically expedient yeah
she didn't come around on marriage
equality until 2013 she initially
supported the TPP and so dropping it
when it became unpopular I think it
really hurts her on the issue of
authenticity yeah no doubt about it and
it's reflected in the polls right no
matter how cuckoo for cocoa puffs you
think Donald Trump is
we know that Hillary Clinton as you
pointed out last week struggles on the
honest and trustworthy as we know that
on some issues she still has trouble
with in the polling and mainstream media
corporate media I'm sorry I try not use
the term mainstream media basically has
not been touching this and we also have
to remember that the country on social
issues and on issues of just basic
taxation should we have progressive or
regressive taxation in the country
inequality should inequality be be
reduced if we can do it up the country
has moved to the left but we still have
the status quo politicians which have
really stayed in in the middle and
whether you call it center left center
or center-right it almost doesn't matter
right the difference between a very
moderate Democrat and a very moderate
Republican is negligible what they say
might vary because of the constituencies
they're trying to raise money from but
practically speaking their views are
going to be very very similar so to me 0
surprise in what Hillary Clinton's
leaked audio here reveals